the Joe Rogan experience we talk assists
yeah when we were at the CDC forget it
I'll never forget it either scariest
[ __ ] interview ever oh not just that
show just devote all time sitting with
that I wish I could remember his name
the guy who ran this is the head of the
place didn't we have some crazy flight -
we flew in and we didn't have any sleep
there's something we missed a flight
because we got stoned and we talked at
the airport and we talked for like a
[ __ ] hour and a half and then
suddenly were like oh [ __ ] our flight
that's right we didn't just miss it by
like five minutes either we missed it by
like 20-30 minutes and we're at the
airport and it was empty at the airport
and we're like oh [ __ ] man we there's we
have to tape the show tomorrow you
remember yeah so we had a fly different
flight and we like barely got an hour
sleep right I think there I think one of
us might have had some magoffin all oh
that's right we took that stuff yeah
that stuff if you've never liked new
Vigil if you've never had or provigil or
new vigil I think they're real similar I
don't remember which one are you used
and provigil is what I used no new vigil
that's what I used definitely you know
the new one and it uh it doesn't it's
not speed now but it definitely gives
you energy and it keeps you awake in the
weirdest way it's like but you're making
it in a great agreement like okay here's
my agreement I want to stay up but I
promise to get sleep from now on I'll
get sleep the next day I'm not gonna
keep using this there's not something
I'm gonna keep using and stay up all the
time no no that's crazy
that's you can use it for that like if
you're a real crazy I know some people
that use that [ __ ] for writing they're
right on that chair and they feel like
without it they don't feel like they
have any energy yeah man I mean that's
the trap of all those things any kind
anything that's any kind of nootropics
gonna do that man it's like but also I
think some people from the sleep
deprivation that's where they become
antennas for the good ideas you know
they like oh yeah it's like fevered
state of not sleeping for days at a time
and go literally insane and somewhere in
there they write really good stuff
that's what the you know news radio the
staff at Newsradio they used to do that
on purpose possums paul sims brilliant
guy the guy who created Newsradio and he
thought it would be a good idea to have
a writing staff filled with a bunch of
psychos who were willing to play video
games and stay up to four o'clock in the
morning every night it was like this mad
vagabond crew of writers that he had
assembled and they would play video
games and just talk [ __ ] and then they
would start writing at like 2:00 a.m.
sometimes but they would come up with
these amazing scripts because and the
scripts were so ridiculous some of them
were so ridiculous and it's because they
were delirious when they were writing
him they were just instead of doing
drugs they were doing the drug of just
staying awake
dude this is for me I've just I'd
started doing this about six months ago
a little longer
waking up at 4:00 a.m. regardless of
when I went to sleep I was having some
insomnia and so I started I realized
like [ __ ] I'll just like wake up when I
wake up and then waking up 4:00 a.m. if
you have insomnia that is going to cure
your [ __ ] insomnia because when night
time rolls around you're exhausted but
not only that 4:00 a.m. is like the
great time for writing weird [ __ ] oh yes
you're still half asleep and the stuff
you write is it's like really feels like
you're tripping you know especially
waking up before him and then like
eating weed I was doing that so you do
eat weed first and then start writing
yeah well know what my system before the
[ __ ] apocalypse was and again I
wasn't doing this every day but I did do
it for a stretch because I got into
David Goggins but 4 a.m. eat we'd go to
the gym and because I was at the gym
because I was at the gym that's where I
would write you were there that early
well no because it would open it I got
there once before the gym opened must
have photo salvage no I didn't do
because what happened was I got to the
gym and then I did I felt pretty [ __ ]
cool but then I went into the car and
I'd like 30 minutes to blow and I'm
[ __ ] stoned man and I'm sitting there
baked and I'm like a bucket I'll just
like sit sit in the car and try to
meditate this is in the parking garage
of the goddamn Hollywood equinox now let
me tell you something man that area of
Hollywood is already [ __ ] weird but
I'm sitting there with my eyes closed
I'm kind of tripping feel like I'm half
asleep half awake I look over there are
two dudes creeping up to my car window
creeping up there and I'm like what the
[ __ ] I was sitting in the passenger side
I jumped to the driver's side started
the car I'm driving through the parking
garage
stoned these two weirdos were definitely
walking up to my car I'm like tripping
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm not
gonna work out and so I leave I'm like
what the [ __ ] I'm gonna let these two
like four am weird vampires stop me from
working out so I drive back in one of
them's like leaning up against a pillar
like just staring at me creepy dude
these people look like The Lost Boys or
something you're probably preying on the
cars of people that go to work out
probably looking for a car to break into
right and that's what like 4 a.m. people
that are out on meth and they know that
this [ __ ] like to go to the gym and
leave their [ __ ] in their car right
there you go there you go it was
terrifying but you know it those that's
what you get at 4 or 5 4 to 5 a.m. is
you get math heads and you get people
who are trying to improve their lives
it's the funniest mix of people you get
people who are like I'm not gonna waste
a [ __ ] second I'm gonna get up early
I'm gonna exercise I'm gonna write
because that's when like I mean this is
a woo idea I feel free to light that
[ __ ] again but like there's an idea of
prana which is like energy and and
there's more energy in the morning than
there is at night so if you get up at 4
you're getting like the the purest most
amount of this [ __ ] so that's why a lot
of people meditate it really early while
I like a lot of monks get up really
early is because like it's a oh no it's
just a very it's the most psychedelic
time way more psychedelic than like
midnight yeah it has
you're having you're exerting some form
of control over your life that
especially right that you're exerting
discipline like my friend Jocko he says
discipline equals freedom he gets up
every morning at 4:30 there you go and
he puts a photo of his watch on
Instagram and usually it says go time or
something like those lines get after it
every [ __ ] day
[Applause]